hello guys welcome to the video number three of this course in this video we are going to learn
about market structure break and market structure shift now what is market structure break let's
suppose that we are in an uptrend right so let me pull out this spot too so let's say we are in an
uptrend right now you can see that the price is making higher high high low higher high high low
when price makes another higher high then it is considered to be a market structure break
okay the continuation the continuation of a trend is called market structure break
now how do we know that the trend is going to continue we look for market structure break which
is when price creates a new higher high and then price creates a new high low creates another higher
high breaking the previous structure so you can see that we are creating higher high high low higher
high low higher high high low and then higher high this higher high broke the previous high so
it means that it should be considered as market structure break let's learn that in a bearish
market condition so it's clear so let me remove that similarly one price is creating lower low
lower high lower low lower high you want to look for market structure break and how do we
identify a market structure break is when price creates another lower low like that now this is
considered to be a market structure break okay as you can see price broke this leg broke the previous
lower low and created another lower low now this is considered to be a market structure break
very simple guys so now let's learn about market structure shift
what is market structure shift let's suppose that we are in a bullish trend so we are creating
high high low high high low high high high high high high but then if you want to identify a
market structure shift you would wait for price to break the previous low okay so we got the higher
high low high high high high high high high high high then we got the lower high if that makes sense
because it broke this structure which means that the market structure has shifted from a bullish
trend to a bearish trend okay so very simple guys when price breaks the previous low
then that price action is considered to be a market structure shift
let's repeat i will repeat that again so you can see that we are continuously making higher
highs high lows higher high high low higher high once the new higher high is made we can then look
for market structure shift after the new high is made we would then look for a market structure
shift which would be when price breaks the previous low the low that was created the low
that was created after in the before a new high i hope that is clear let's give let me give you an
example for a bearish to bullish market so let's suppose that we are in a whoops my bad let's
suppose that we are in a bearish market okay so we continuously making lower low lower high lower
low lower high lower low when the new lower low is made and if you want to and if you are looking
for market structure shift then we would wait for price to break the previous lower high okay
so we made lower low lower high lower low lower high lower low and then what we would wait for
is for price to break the previous high okay so as you can see after the new lower low was made
we then wait for price to break the previous low which would be this now this is considered to be
a market structure shift for a bearish example so i really hope that by now it should be clear
that what is market structure break and what what is a market structure shift okay very simple
when market shifts basically it means that their trend has shifted and by market structure break
it means that their trend is going to continue so keep these concepts in your mind and i'll
see you guys in the next video